uh they also do nuggets now these are
the basic kind which i i you'd never
catch me finding i just i don't know
i want a spice there's like there's a
hot version and i think there's a cheese
version
yeah yeah i don't [ __ ] with the cheese
versions because it's like injected
cheese
i don't trust that she should be on top
it should never be injected
right there's some things that should be
injected
cheese isn't one of the vaccines like
check yes medicine
medicine check and uh these have been
microwaved because we've heated them up
but uh yeah they don't it doesn't look
too great not gonna lie you guys want to
try a nugget yeah i mean the color on
this chicken is
kind of tragic looking honestly i did
eat one before recording something this
looks actually this is the most
depressing chicken
you know what this looks like this looks
like like this is like frozen
yeah look how yellow this is it was once
frozen and i just defrosted it it's it's
like it does it lacks
any kind of color that makes it look
that would make it look oh yeah
oh no that ain't good no they had a
slime done
7-eleven family mod and then whatever
the [ __ ] i just say okay
that was worse than the family mart
chicken
i said the family mart chicken tastes
like death oh my god
yeah that was this looks like this
tastes right out the freezer
yeah oh my god you know what this tastes
like this tastes like can you show can
you put it like
stab it and show it to the camera okay
this
look at that look at that this for real
tastes like the skin is
like dying to get off it this is like
one of those kadagas you order at a
really really cheap yeah it's like it's
like 50 yen friday 50 yen for one yeah
yeah yeah yeah that ain't chief man the
fight but i mean honestly you can't
really go wrong unless you go family
mart
yeah i i would say the reason that
i mean we okay so where we live right
now we live right next to a family mart
and we live right next to a lawsons
unfortunately we don't live next to a
7-eleven
and that's a shame for me because some
of my best food items like the fried
chicken
and like some of the other things i'm
going to show off today is from 7-eleven
that's why like every time you see a set
of eleven it's like an event right now
oh definitely it's like a random
encounter
yeah i'm like yo i can get the fried
chicken right now
i'll be right back i just had lunch but
finna grab a friend be right back boys
they also have a bunch of it's not just
these they have tons of other hot food
items they have like
it's like a pizza bread with like
fillings like folded up and then they
microwave it well and the other one that
i have right here well no the one i have
here is uh like a cushy
like uh skewered meat oh i have that as
well oh okay yeah these are like the
snack ones they have like like
me again i don't think i've ever ordered
these before but
they look like that that's that just
looks like a yakiniku yeah
i have never ordered it's yakitori oh
yeah
i've never ordered this i've never
ordered this
i don't have a yakitori you don't well
you can charge something i'll try
something
here honestly these don't look like you
look at you look at these on camera
and they don't look any different from
each other at all i couldn't tell which
one the lawsons
uh of those yakitori is and i can't tell
which one is the family mariakitori
i've never gotten the yakitori uh which
is like skewered
like barbecued skewed meats right do you
feel like i'm playing with fire you know
what i mean
because these both of these the color of
them
the coloring just there is no coloring
at all don't go to a like any kind of
convene store to get yakitori there's
plenty of amazing yakitori restaurants
all over tokyo it's so cheap as well
normally you can buy per
skewer yeah it's like you know some of
the cheaper places like 30 in a skewer
i'll try the family mart one first okay
let's try the family
that's awful that is so bad that is bad
that is bad okay i think i think this
has to be fresh it's because we
microwaved these yeah yeah
this what it tastes like is they
didn't know how to flavor this so so
they just put as much salt on this as
possible yeah this is salted like
[ __ ] this is salt and oil what i'm
tasting right now is just
very salty oil i just stabbed into the
lawson and it like
squirted like straight up squirted oil
all right let me try that let's try the
laws
let me try the lawson's one hmm i don't
know they're just both as bad as each
other yeah they're not that good yeah
that's pretty fun bottom lane don't go
to a convenience store to get yakitori
lots of amazing izakayas and restaurants
to go to for that
i feel like we need a drink to go along
with this amazing food
ashley get us a drink have we talked
about ashley before in this podcast
we talked about him on the live
livestream that we did but yes
we had we now have a intern
we hired uh our new intern ashley uh
what he did was he sent
a full cv to us
do you actually have a beer so i can
wash this down sorry oh
no oh no oh no
at least at least he did us a favor and
got the mini ones do you want to explain
what this is true yeah so this is
uh ozeki's one cup sake
which is essentially the like trailer
trash
level of sake that you can get at the
convenience stores ah imagine if
budweiser
tried to make a cheap version of
budweiser and this is what you would
this is the blue lightning of sake
right so how much does one of these cost
these cost like a dollar a pop
it's like 100 yen yeah yeah 200 okay 250
yen
that's too much for this yeah so that
this is this costs about two dollars
it's a literally a jar of sake and we
all know how much i love sake yeah from
the episode
honestly i have none of us have tried
this right i've never tried i've never
tried this either so i'm not even a big
fan of sake um
it's like wine right like i need the
right food for it and this is not the
right food
if you calculate the uh the price per
milliliter
this is actually more expensive than one
crisp brought us so could
actually if it's to 250 yen yeah pretty
well oh yeah probably
so chris you [ __ ] cheap [ __ ]
well it doesn't smell horrible well it's
sack it never smells of anything much
it doesn't it doesn't smell too bad i
mean it smells like sake what does bad
sake smell like a bad sake will smell
sour like you'll know why why okay that
why
that's like having milk and being like
this this smells this smells sounds
like legit like you wanna throw this
away yeah
legit like i've had bad sake before and
it's it's sour
it's it's like sour milk but like sake
it's it's horrible all right well i
guess we gotta
try this huh so she all do at the same
time yeah she is
gentleman okay successful podcast i hope
yes
all right let's give it a shot shall we
oh god that's actually no that's not
bad at all what that i was not i was
expecting a burn
or a bad aftertaste that's not
you know what i can't believe i'm saying
this i'm kind of [ __ ] with this like
it actually tastes alright you want mine
come on
i don't [ __ ] this man just cannot
drink saga this is actually
i was expecting it to feel like i'm
drinking petrol
yeah that's what i was expecting as well
japan
this is the cheap alternative to like
getting pissed in japan
i can see all these like you know like
old people go into
uh you know 7-eleven or wherever buy one
of these and just chill at the front of
the seven left yeah
i would probably be there as honestly
this is why we like uh this is why
kombini is a great because sometimes you
buy something and it's
way better than you expect to buy the
convenience store this sake
tastes way too good to for something
that just came out of a 250 yen
convenience
it's actually not bad wow it doesn't
really taste of much that's why i mean
it's easy to drink yeah
it's really easy to drink because a lot
of like cheap sake usually has like a
very
harsh honestly it's less i think it's
less offensive than the one that chris
wrote the other day actually this
actually tastes better than on the
christmas yeah yeah yeah
so chris [ __ ] us over thanks i'm still
going to stay what i'm saying is the
milliliter
price ratio